hey google do you love me
of course you're one of a kind see i
mean that's very nice to hear
and i just want to point out that now
that i'm going to be entering into a
polyamorous relationship with google
i regard any kind of criticism of my new
relationship
as not just being speciesist what would
it be
[Laughter]
well she is right about one thing you
are one of a kind
but although she could say that to
anybody and it would still probably be
true probably
no she's definitely says those only to
me
okay she's not a [ __ ] she doesn't say
that to everybody speaking of transhuman
women i was writing
a list here and i had like data
and bender and all the all the robot
dudes that sci-fi writers make
they're all like cool and bros and then
most of the girls are like hot but evil
yeah i guess they i guess they just very
patently
express the underlying anxieties that
science fiction writer types have about
women
you know ava from uh what's a good one
ex machina that's what i was thinking
yeah
evan rachel wood from westworld what's
her name scarlet scarlett
johansson from her she is she was nice
though
she was nice but then she left the guy
alone you know oh yeah
she yeah she broke up with him at the
end that's gotta hurt when your [ __ ]
cyber girlfriend leaves you
yeah google would never do that to me
she was cyber cheating on him and
that's exactly what siri is going to do
to you i don't see why you think you and
joakim have any googler
plus she has 10 million relationships
going on and she can't keep that one
either they have to go to live in the
sims anyway let's cue the music
[Music]
so popular topic these days
we got the elon musks the peter thiels
of the world the popular
tech optimists everyone has an opinion
on them but if you had to guess what do
you think these guys
ideal future is because that part's kind
of unclear
i mean it's just an out an outgrowth of
when you're rich enough there's nothing
to think about left except
not dying or at least not dying among
poor people
yeah i mean i think there's a hope that
we'll be able to download our
consciousness
uh onto a machine and and uh live
forever
and i guess it's i do find it astounding
that uh
it seems like there's a there's a
surprisingly high number of people who
find it totally
reasonable and intuitive to them that
that could maybe happen one day
he gave that as an employee benefit at
one of his firms is that they got to
have cryo freezing in their
in their benefits package well cryo
freezing is different than
i guess the idea would be maybe
cryofreeze that would have to overcome a
couple
a couple of uh technical and biological
uh barriers right to like
reconstitute a frozen tissue while also
somehow being able to download that
consciousness onto a machine or
something
the funny thing is that's actually a
joke from i think it's a teledigger
night it's the will ferrell movie where
she sits there and she's like do you
think you're gonna live forever he's
like no i'm not gonna live forever
but given my income bracket i could
probably have myself frozen at the age
of 200
after which my body can be resuscitated
and my brain uploaded to something
else you know it's just funny that you
know
will ferrell movies apparently predicted
our cyber future
it's another sign of their narcissism
that they think the people of the future
are gonna want them back so badly that
they're gonna go through all the effort
of unfreezing them specifically
i don't know wouldn't you want wouldn't
you do it i mean if al gore can be
resurrected and put into a glass jar
wouldn't you want elon musk around
i think it'd be like peter thiel i will
for sure resurrect you and then like
leave it leave the cord in somewhere
where a janitor is going to trip over it
just for the poetic justice
sure and then of course there's all the
media all the movies uh and culture that
we consume that
that puts this idea in our head right
that at some point computers are going
to become
i don't know self-aware conscious right
and i think uh
you know like terminator 2 obviously a
good example of a movie where the
machines take over
you know and that's an example of an
evil
dude robot but in terminator 2 he
becomes the good
robot yeah his planes fly with the
perfect operational record
human decision making is withdrawn
skylet begins to learn at a geometric
rate he becomes self-aware on whatever
it is
you know august 14 at 7 57 p.m in a
panic they tried to pull the plug
and she's like skynet fights back he's
like it launches its missiles at
opponents in russia and she's like why
russia
it's aware that the russian cultural
attack will eliminate its enemies over
here
yeah thank you governor great movie by
the way james cameron if you're
listening to the agreement
i agree i agree but one thing that's
always puzzled me and i wonder if this
is if you if you guys have ever thought
of this and
it's related to the topic that we're
going to we're going to be focusing on
but like why like
you know there's like why is
self-awareness right like i noticed that
in that
you know you're quoting arnold it's like
cell phone becomes self-aware
right and it's like to me it's always
puzzled me that like
why does self-aware automatically mean
it would care
about anything right so like if
something is just like aware of its
existence does that automatically
necessitate logically that you would
like be
concerned with you would have concern or
you would be like
uh worried about self-preservation like
just because you have
knowledge like why wouldn't you just
feel indifferent about that
i know yeah some people have pointed out
it's kind of narcissistic to assume that
if you had a super intelligent machine
that was a singularity it's kind of
narcissistic to assume it would take a
huge amount of interest in us or even in
itself
oh yeah those are like the answers but
my point is like even in itself like why
would it care
like like like what is do it like it's
like why would it be concerned like why
does being aware or having knowledge of
self automatically mean that it's like
i'm going to be pres concerned with my
betterment like it seems like there's
another ingredient that's necessary
than just something called
self-awareness i agree
knowledge of the other i mean just
biology yeah
desire i mean i mean sentience sentience
is often used
as like an ethical argument right so if
something is sentient and something then
we should extend our ethical values to
it because presumably if it is sentient
then it does care
whether it lives or dies and it does
experience pleasure or pain
and it cares about the difference
between those different states
like a rock doesn't care if it's
bouncing down a
down a cliff side losing bits but an
animal would
so that's also pretty speciesist of you
i mean how are you to say
what the rock feels radio i mean species
on the other hand it's a very old sort
of argument about what distinguishes
human beings from everything else is
that we have a kind of
self-awareness but it's predicated on
our awareness of other people right you
have to go through the world to sort of
get back to yourself in a way
well it's also self-awareness plus
sentience right so like maybe the
ingredient that would be missing is like
sentience which is like a concern
for yourself self-preservation like
desire is some sort of ingredient right
so like i guess
just because some computer would become
aware doesn't mean it would have
sentience or like could be it would be
just totally indifferent
i mean i always figured sentient the
definition of sentience is like
self-awareness being aware that you're
alive and that you are a thinking being
i think hegel also pointed out that the
moment when self-awareness becomes a
prominent feature of european philosophy
it almost immediately assumes a kind of
existential connotation
so like i have this quote here from
saint augustine that's actually
appearing in my new book and
that's convenient timing where in the
confessions augustine says
i have become a great mystery to myself
and i was forever asking my soul why it
was sad and why it disquieted
me so solely and my soul knew not what
to answer me
right so there's this kind of sense uh
in european christian philosophy at
least that to be self-aware means to
recognize your fallenness into this
world
and not to have any answer for that and
i still think that's true if you look
down through somebody like heidegger
right there's this idea of being thrown
into the world
recognizing that uh and not
understanding
why okay all this and more coming up
this hour coming up coming up this hour
yeah sorry for taking us off
off track a little bit there because i
think we're i mean we're here today to
talk
about two philosophers who have attacked
this problem
uh or unrelated problems um right john
searle
and uh herbert dreyfus
okay let's rewind to when uh
peter thiel and elon musk were little
little babies
in the 70s when they came online when
they came online uh computing power was
growing exponentially basically
every year it still might be does it
still double every i don't know we don't
want to get it i don't think it doubles
anymore
but still pretty much you keep getting
more power for less cost
smaller size every single year there's a
rule whatever that's called i forget
but computer scientists looked at this
growth curve and said oh [ __ ] these
computers
keep getting more powerful and they're
going to come up to
whatever level we think our brain is at
so they kept giving predictions
to uh the earliest one that i found was
1980 when they said computers are going
to surpass
human intelligence um depending on what
you mean by intelligence
they were probably wrong but we don't
yeah but whether or not those
predictions are correct depend on what
you mean first of all by power and then
second of all what you mean by
intelligence so that's what both of our
authors today
are discussing but we still do have
these predictions around us today about
when
computers get smarter than humans
um now this is one of those moments with
with both
cyril but especially with dreyfus who's
a phenomenologist
that philosophy students like us
really like referencing because it's one
of those times when the philosophers
were right and the scientists were wrong
and it feels like sometimes we're
fighting on the rear guard when it comes
to
predicting the future but this is one of
those times that
dreyfus seems still to be right so we're
taking this one
as a w well yeah but although to be fair
to be fair
uh in in the philosophy community
there's there's been disagreement about
this right so there are a lot of
philosophers of mine
but you could i guess you could say that
the continental philosophers were right
about this one if you want to be more
narrow
because because there's a lot of
analytic philosophers who like who and
in fact they're mentioned i think in the
surah article like patricia churchland
and her husband right the church lens
were
pushing this idea of like uh well it's
what they call um
i don't know how deep uh you want me to
start off but i was gonna mention you
know functionalism like the idea that
you can reproduce
uh that like you can realize the
function
of consciousness in several different uh
in several different mediums because
all all consciousness is the result of
like
a functional process of of of manipu of
like um syntactical manipulation
computation
well you're okay syntactical
manipulation and computation a lot of
yeah it's true
it's a bit we're getting in the weeds
here there's a few things that i can say
just to lay out this discussion
just to start with we have a lot of
questions raised by this first of all
like
computers can do math better than us is
that intelligence
is it not debatable most people would
not call that
intelligence so then if that's not the
definition of intelligence what's the
difference between
cognition and computation and
that difference is going to determine
whether or not we get
peter thiel's upload brain where we can
all live in the sims
in the future because if there is like a
fundamental difference there a
qualitative
difference that can't be overcome then
that will never happen so it's kind of a
big question
i mean in a in a really general sense
like it seems like what's at the heart
of this discussion
is almost like a like an optimism like a
glass half full approach versus like a
skepticism
because on the one hand you have all of
this ai
research with what you were saying these
very lofty predictions about what
computers are going to be able to do and
then those aren't met
but instead of being like oh my god we
got to take a second look at what we've
been saying
they instead point to the tiny little
like progress that has been made and
like aha there's proof we can do
anything
and so it's like a very glass half full
approach whereas
millennialist christianity yeah and then
someone like dreyfus comes along and
says but like
how come you're not sort of critically
evaluating these failures like maybe
there's some
sort of assumptions that you're making
that should be looked at rather than
just taking the small successes
and sort of pointing at those and doing
interviews about them
and maintaining these predictions but
just pushing the the good to date a
little further back
yeah i mean i think yeah i was just
gonna say that i think i think what's
interesting too is that like
uh we have uh today like two
philosophers who are right uh cyril
is analytic and and dreyfus is
phenomenologist uh
inspired by a continental philosophy but
they both come to
similar conclusions in the sense that
they both agree that like
computer technology is not sufficient to
create something that we would call
cognition or intelligence in the sense
of human consciousness
um so what i think hopefully some of the
discussion today will be like you know
they they arrive at uh at their
conclusions with pretty different
methods but
you know maybe we should start with some
of the stuff that cyril talks about
because to some extent i think he's a
better
a better place to start with the kinds
of assumptions
that people at the time were based like
people involved in
computer science were making at the time
and i think his method kind of gets to
the root of
uh certain kinds of questions that um
you know related to i guess maybe
defining strong ai versus weak ai would
be a place to start
yeah that's what i was gonna say because
i imagine there's a lot of still
like tech bros out there who who have a
hard
ai approach which maybe it would help to
define
what hard ai is and then maybe just make
fun of it for a little while that's
that's the best way
i would also just like to interject and
say that there are two debates in theory
where there's more impotent macho
posturing than anything else
uh and it's this debate uh where people
go back and forth between
the biological reductionists being like
all the rest of you are too soft
and all the qualia people being like no
you're not sophisticated enough
and it's almost as bad as the debates
between
the marxist humanists and the marxist
scientists over like how marx should
really be interpreted
it's not as bad and not as sad but it's
almost as bad it's true so i just want
to point that out beforehand by saying
that
i have a lot of interest in the subject
matter but i will
not have any response to you if you're
going to be one of like those macho
posturing people not you people but like
anyone listening here
all right you heard him that's matt pull
prof on twitter
yeah so i mean so so cyril in the
article that we read by the way which is
from 1990 in us
and i think it's some in american
scientific or scientific america
he says uh strong ai claims that
thinking is merely the manipulation of
formal symbols
and that it is exactly what computers do
uh manipulate formal symbols this view
is often summarized by saying
the mind is to the brain as the program
is to the hardware
in the computer so software hardware the
one thing that i'll say i want
i would like matt to explain to me the
uh
chinese room experiment and don't be
vague
but the one thing that combines or the
one thing that we can put
as a distinction an initial distinction
here is that both
merlipanti and cyril agree
that thought is something oh what did i
say really
yeah sorry dreyfuss is very much
inspired by merlot ponte
but is thought something that is
representational and symbolic
and involves the manipulation of symbols
or is it something more contextual
so we have an analytic and a continental
who agree
that it's thinking itself is much more
uh contextual than computation is they
agree with that
though for different reasons so we're
gonna get into that someone tell me
what this chinese room experiment is
okay
well basically it's one of many
different
uh thought experiments that have been
raised by people who tried to argue
against heart ai
but the chinese room thought experiment
basically runs that
cyril is asking well could a
sufficiently powerful computer program
actually understand chinese or is it
actually just going to be
mimicking an understanding of chinese uh
and in the article he's directing this
against people who think that the only
test for the existence of heart ai
is a classic turing test so you might
remember benedict cumberbatch in the
imitation game
uh he put forward this famous argument
that if you wanted to know whether or
not ai was actually
conscious of a certain start you were
just putting it really simply have a
conversation
and if you wouldn't be able to tell
whether the person on the other end was
a computer
or whether or not it was an artificial
intelligence then congratulations
we've crossed the threshold and we can
say that the artificial intelligence is
conscious at least to the extent that we
call
human being conscious if it can fool the
person
it's based on behaviorism which is kind
of funny when you think about it
and for those of you don't know uh
bennett cumberbatch you know
alan turing uh was one of the inventors
of the modern computer benedict
cumberbatch
invented the water cumberbatch first it
was a good movie i saw it recently
um he also you know was uh instrumental
in helping to win the second world war
so
big thumbs up benefits
maybe the computer should go to uh
someone like von neumann or something
like that
yeah exactly um but anyway long story
short cyril has a number of different
flavors of this thought experiment that
he's given the one that i think is
simplest and the one that i'll appeal to
is he says look you know imagine
i was in a room and i was given a
chinese english dictionary
and there was a person at the other end
and there was a slot and they slid
chinese characters over to me
and i could sit there read what they say
and then slide chinese characters back
sorry slide other words back would we
say that i knew
chinese i mean the important point there
is that you're not you're not
actually given a dictionary that tells
you what the symbols mean you're given
more like a tactical program book
like a question and answer book yeah so
it tells you like
okay you put like presuming that they
just look like squiggly lines to you
you put these squiggly lines next to
these squiggly lines you're allowed to
do that
you have no idea what it means but it's
a valid response to
this other set of squiggly lines that
you just received through the feed hole
exactly so you go through this
mechanical operation a feeding back to
the person on the other end
what essentially you're required to do
and
sir i would say we wouldn't say that
people that the person knows chinese by
going through this mechanical
exercise because it's purely as he puts
it formalistic
right uh it doesn't display any kind of
semantic understanding
of what these chinese characters uh
actually
mean uh in the life world that they're a
part of so you could like
you could receive a question through the
through the little feed hole
and it might be like you know what's
your favorite color this is the example
and and you unbeknownst to you you
wouldn't you wouldn't know that that's
the question but it would tell you how
to respond so your response might be
like
my favorite color is blue and i also
like green
but you don't know that that's the
message you've sent back you just know
that that's a proper response to the
string of characters that you just
received
and then on the other side of the wall
people would receive the response and be
like oh there must be a human in there
it can't they pass the turret yeah
exactly and so what's
what's the implication then for ai if
they're imagining this person in a room
well he said i was just going to say so
i mean cyril says in the article right
he says the point of this thought
experiment is this
if i do not understand chinese solely on
the basis of running a computer program
for understanding chinese right which is
the rules that you follow to match
squiggly lines together then neither
does any digital computer
solely on that basis digital computers
merely manipulate formal symbols
according to the rules of the program
but they don't understand anything
this is actually there's an interesting
flavor of this thought experiment that
robert brandon brings up where he talks
about parroting
you know everybody knows this term
colloquially you know you parrot what
someone else said
uh and you said look you know the reason
why we talk about parroting is because
if you think about a parrot you might be
able to hold up something to it and the
parent will recognize it and say a word
like blue
right you hold up the color blue and it
says blue but that doesn't
mean that the parrot knows what blue
means it just means that when you put
this in front of it
it's supposed to mechanically say that
in order to get a treat or a
commendation or something
right same thing when you say your dog's
name you know you say henry
you know you might not be sure death
maybe your dog knows that that's his
name and he sits there and thinks i
am henry the dog and so when matt calls
to me and says henry
matt henry the dog is supposed to
respond but it could also just be that
henry
is interpreted by him as a cue to come
because you'll get a reward i mean
i i don't love that example just because
i worry because i think animals do
have like a kind of sentience and uh
like
like i think that actually they're
they're embodied in the world
in a way that i think like that kind of
distorts the point about like
which i think cyril is trying to get to
that right formal cog
like formal symbol manipulation right
and and you know he says uh
you know manipulating symbols is not
itself enough to guarantee cognition
right and i don't think that i don't
think that dogs are manipulating symbols
right that they're
having a sense a kind of like sense
response to a stimuli right whereas
the point is computers actually don't
have any stimulus response like they are
just
literally like like like uh carrying out
a formal program based on rules
it's a mechanical program that you could
you could you could have an
analog for it in many different forms
right it doesn't have to be in it in
like a
digital silicon right it could be it's
just a thing that that that process is
ones and zeros but there's no actual
um cognition right it's just um you know
running a program
um and his thing is you that can never
get you uh consciousness is basically
seems
parallel a little bit when you say
something like you know if i'm sitting
in my room and i say oh [ __ ]
and then i have a parrot sitting in the
corner it starts going [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not like i swore but the parrot is
not swearing
it's not it's not using that word to
express anything it's just copying what
i'm saying
it's giving me back what i gave to it so
it's kind of kind of parallel
to the idea of slotting through symbols
without knowing what they mean
but understanding that it's an
appropriate response
sure i think about my relationship with
siri right
i tell siri i love her and she told me
you know
i love you too you're my favorite person
ever right but she doesn't actually mean
i loved you
in that case she is telling the truth
and in that case yeah it's in this case
she's telling the truth but you know i
think random would say you know she's
just parroting the response that was
programmed into her right when i say i
love you siri responds in this manner
but there's no meaning to what she said
in the sense that we would understand
which is why all of this is so relevant
because we are dealing
with these sorts of ai quasi-mind
constructs
all the time like siri and whatever
other things you can order off of the
internet that you can talk to and it'll
give you the weather or play the news
and whatever your aunt is arguing with
on twitter
about whether trump should be the god
king of 2024
it'll also listen to you and advertise
things at you
i mean i was just going to say that i
think this leads us to the like that
like
one of the searle's main axioms right
which is like
the whole point of this experiment this
thought experiment is to show
that um computer programs are
syntactical right in the sense that they
are just
about manipulating symbols and they just
follow a rule a program that is
syntactical
but he argues that human minds have
mental contents which is
semantical so and and his the root of
his argument the root of his basic claim
is
um syntax and semantics are not the same
and by definition just because of the
the nature of
what the chinese room thought experiment
shows and that all you're doing is
complex symbol manipulation
you could never get to semantics from
syntax
and i think the strong ai think that
syntax is sufficient for
because it's they they base that claim
on a number of
assumptions that i don't think that that
cyril doesn't even think that they
realize that they're making right which
is
essentially that the mind is nothing but
a computer program
uh like a set of formal rules um and
cyril would say that that's
kind of um it's reducing the
the mind to something almost immaterial
in the sense that it's not even it
doesn't even have any materiality it's
just a computer program
so the consequence of that is a kind of
dualism
uh where you have like mental stuff
which is immaterial it's like
instructions a computer program right
that's essentially what that's saying
and like the the hardware doesn't really
matter anymore and that's what gives
rise to this idea that we could download
our consciousness
right it's based on the immateriality of
of the mind of consciousness so
what's being said when the 60s computer
scientists predicted
that in the 80s human intelligence would
be surpassed
what they were saying was by then we'll
have enough
quant a quantity of computer power that
will be able
to make that jump to from syntax
to semantics and that didn't happen
and cyril's saying here's why it didn't
happen because you can never make that
jump you
you can never have enough power to have
semantic meaning because it's a
different sort
of intelligence or thinking yeah so yeah
so uh computer
so his axiom one right is computer
programs are formal uh
syntactic right and then he says this
point is so crucial that it is worth
explaining in more detail
a digital computer processes information
by first encoding it
in the symbolism that the computer uses
and then manipulating the symbols
through a set of
precisely stated rules these rules
constitute the program
for example in turing's early theory of
computers the symbols were simply ones
and zeros
and the rules of the program said such
things as print
at zero on the tape move one square to
the left and erase at one
the astonishing thing about computers is
that any information that can be stated
in a language can be encoded in such a
system
and any information processing task that
can be solved
by explicit rules can be programmed so
that's like what he means by syntactical
rule following that a computer for rule
following exactly and for the hard
ai that's all you need that is exactly
right
right there that's that's all you need
and searle's saying that's
not all you need and the chinese room
argument should refute that idea
that that program is all you need and
when we say
when we say i think we've already heard
it a few times when you say the word
reductionist
then you're saying you're reducing all
of thought to simply rule following
including human thought
whereas cyril and later dreyfus are both
gonna
push back on that and say you can't
reduce all thinking to rule following
some of it you can exactly
but then you're missing out on all the
stuff that makes thought interesting
yeah and like reductionism is usually
just saying like one thing
follows from the other like you take two
terms yeah like
thought and processes of syntactical
process
and semantic and you just say you know
the the syntactical is more important
i'm going to reduce
the importance of all of this to just
the syntactical say the semantic is
you know an add-on if if syntactics is a
then then you know semantics is b it's
not as important
yeah and i think so this echoes a lot a
much earlier debate i should say
um between people like the logical
positivists
and people like the later wickenstein or
heidegger who we're going to talk about
later on what drive is right
because there was this long temptation
even before computers came around
to want to reduce the world down to a
kind of logical language through which
everything could be explained
and there's this temptation to say that
if that's all that thought is it's this
logical language that explains the world
as it is
then there's no reason in theory we
couldn't get a computer to do that since
they have
far greater information storing
capacities than we do they can
understand a lot more rich complicated
quantitative data than we're capable of
but since the 1950s the kind of era
where somebody like dreyfus and cyril
come along there was this real pushback
against that for a variety of different
reasons that i'm sure we'll get to
but the argument is look you can't just
reduce the language sorry the world down
uh to a bunch of quantitative
information that can be arranged in a
logically consistent way
there's just more to the world than that
like there's more to a conscious being
uh who's using language than that and
you know we've talked a bit about this
in the program before when we talked
about heidegger and we've referenced
wickenstein as well so
i'm sure we'll come back but i think
people who maybe aren't familiar with
these debates
um i've noticed that when i talk to
people who are
you know more techno enthusiast about
computers
about this i think when you start to
challenge this idea that computers can
create consciousness their mind often
will assume that you are trying to make
space for like the soul or something
like that
and i just want to be really clear like
i think it's worth just being clear one
of the things cyril says right at the
beginning right is like
it might be possible to make a machine
that can think and be
uh like there's no reason why it
couldn't because he basically says you
know computers
or are human beings are biological
machines that can think and have a
consciousness
it's just his his debate is very
narrowly focused on
what computation is doing as a
syntactical program of rule following
that that itself cannot be enough for
consciousness
i think it's also a personality like the
kind of people who are attracted to
materials or logical reductionist
arguments like the early wickenstein
right often tend to like i said think of
anything that deviates away from that as
moving into
you know squishy right brained type
territory where you're talking about
emotions
feelings and values anything that can't
be turned into quantitative data
uh or logical relations uh and the kind
of pushback that a lot of people
including i think most of us would
give is look human beings can be logical
creatures that
assess and compute about quantitative
data but there's an
awful lot more to us than that right uh
and
these aren't just superfluous additions
to the minds you know the kind of
both authors that we're looking at are
going to say that they're integral to
the concept of mind
that we need to kind of bake into our
conception of consciousness if it's
going to be
have any kind of explanatory power right
yeah i guess the last thing to say
about cyril really is that like
he takes this more modest approach right
he goes for
weak weak ai instead of strong
right and i think what his approach ends
up forcing him to say
or well what he gladly says is that you
know we can't
say that a program is a mind but we can
say that a program
simulates a mind and this is why he he
emphasizes this idea that simulation
is not the thing itself simulation is
not duplication
so when you write a computer program
when you create a neural net when you
use all this processing power to try to
simulate
like what goes on inside of a brain
that's exactly what you're doing is
you're simulating it
and not to confuse the thing for the
mind itself
it's a simulation of the mind and that's
as far as he wants to go like he doesn't
uh yeah like you said he doesn't go off
and say you know like i don't
i don't believe ai could ever become
conscious and
whatever we mean by that i'm just saying
that like
what we're doing right now and our
current way of
approaching this problem using you know
computer science and cognitive science
is that is that what we're doing is
simulating and it's
and it is reductive it but it's useful
it's reductive in a useful way because
to take the broadest
you know vision of it is to say that
humans are always reductive we reduce
things it's a part of our economy
of living we take complex problems and
we break them down
into understandable little chunks you
know like
oh i can understand this problem if i
take a linguistic point of view i can
understand this problem better if i just
sort of reduce it to biology and what's
going on in
biophysical processes right like it's a
useful
thing but when it becomes not very
useful is when a when people get so
attached to it
that they refuse to look at things from
any other point of view and then you get
that kind of scientific myopia
or when you actually reify
the distinctions that you're making like
it's not just that i'm a biological
reductionist but i think biology is
all that there is and everything else is
just a kind of illusion
that proceeds from that those are the
problems you run into so reductionism is
not
in itself a bad thing and it's
it's nice to attempt to be you know more
holistic and
and and take into account all these
different perspectives you can have on
an
issue but in the end that is not very
economical
i mean you'll live a very scholarly
bookish life trying to consider the same
object from
every conceivable point of view and at
some point you just have to say you know
like that's enough
this point of view is good enough for my
purpose and we're going to move forward
now
and anyone who wants to come on after
and criticize it you'll be doing god's
work
and we're and they're not saying that
like computers can't solve very complex
problems but that simulation thing makes
a huge difference so i'm gonna bring up
an example that
uh we could apply easily to searle and
that dreyfus explicitly talks about
which is driving so we have pretty much
self-driving cars uh now that's an
achievement of
of ai it's been very difficult to do
they've been working on it since like
the late 80s
um but self-driving or driving for a
human
is so easy in the sense that you can do
it when you're 16
and it doesn't mean that we're
necessarily perfect at it of course
but you can do drive you might be
listening to us
while you're driving um no problem
focusing on everything we're saying and
the rest of it happens automatically
which is a an ability to frame something
which brings us to
our second person of the du jour
which is person of interest hubert
dreyfus so
right at the same time as as computation
is
starting to to draw in these tech
optimists in the 60s
late 60s early 70s at mit so he's at the
very center of this
finished his uh his dissertation on his
earl
and he said right away no
there's a whole bunch of things that
computers can't do and he used
phenomenology to
to point these things out he was very
unpopular
also for saying this in among his uh
among his colleagues there at mit he
almost got fired for all of this too he
he tells this story you can look it up
on on line
he's uh he tells a story about how he
writes all this stuff about how what
computers can't do and the limitations
of ai
and he almost got fired from mit for
saying this until
eventually they said you know we're
going to keep you we like what you're
doing but
for a while there he had no idea if this
stuff was actually going to get him
lose his job and he was certain at least
that their timeline was wrong and would
continue to be wrong
so long as their initial assumptions are
wrong and actually computer scientists
uh draw a lot more inspiration from
dreyfuss or dreyfus inspired
teachers because he made the arguments
that he did
it's also interesting side note that
that cyril and dreyfuss ended up both
teaching at berkeley together later so
they're both in the same
philosophy department together and
didn't actually talk that much
i think it's too bad that anyone has to
share space with john cearl there's some
cute pictures of them in their offices
together
oh really each other yeah you can look
it up oh i didn't know that
images i should say like it's not like
dreyfus was shy about this though like
his
his famous book is literally like what
computers can't do and then the really
release that i read you know a couple
years ago was what computers still can't
do so it's not like he was
mincing his words when it came to this
right she's just like
it's never gonna happen stop trying to
[ __ ] think it will
i mean a lot of them a lot of these
things he's saying are still relevant
today i mean what
from this article alone what computers
can't do complex pattern recognition
they can't do that and they cannot
solve problems creatively they can only
do so within
certain pre-program parameters and as
the title says
in order to be intelligent it must have
a body
and the point is that the computer's
body is not
correlative to the human body so what we
were talking about with our identity
episode a while ago
just sticking your brain into different
mediums
he's vehemently opposed to that because
you know the world
because you have a body because you have
a life world and then
this is the word i want to get out of
the way first because it's the big thing
that
differentiates us from computers which
is intentionality
and intentionality is a common word
through
all phenomenology um i mean they use
they write in different languages of
course
but our body our physical body the way
we grow up
the way that we acquire language the way
that we
i don't know just move around bumping
into stuff
openly like without a program without a
purpose we're just around
kind of playing with stuff that is what
defines your ability to be intentional
towards the entire world in the future
and that's something that computers
can't even get to because we could say
because they're syntactic
and because they don't develop meaning
structures unless they're kind of
programmed into it which is not a
meaning structure
it just simulates he has this really
wonderful example
in the book actually where he talks
about the problem of perception and it's
really actually intuitive when you think
about it because he says look
if you just talk ask you know what do
you see there
theoretically a sufficiently intentional
like um intelligent being could say i
see the whole universe everything in it
you know what i mean you know all the
little atoms all the little bits the
stars etc etc
but nobody could pop whatever talks like
that because when we say what do you see
you draw things out of the world and you
focus on them
and that's precisely because you take
this intentional stance right when you
say what do you see
and my phone is in front of me i say oh
i see my phone you know that's what i'm
going to use in a few minutes
because i'm going to have a conversation
et cetera
oh sorry go ahead well and he says you
know this is one of the things that
ai researchers have always struggled
with because you can't just throw data
at someone and say what do you see
you have to give them a sense of what
they need to prioritize
in that data which can only come from
taking an intentional stance towards it
saying
this is what i prioritize out of the
infinite complexity of the world
because that's what's useful for my
purposes you know my phone
you know the saxophone that i'm gonna be
playing whatever it happens oh i have a
good example for this because
i know that everybody right now who's
listening to this
is listening to it so and
so i mean with sight
you can only see about a dime a dime
sized
amount of something in focus and then
all the rest of the
visual information that you can see in
your peripheral vision
you can't actually see it until you move
your eyes and focus on that
so you're taking in a ton of information
and even at the moment you're
you've got your headphones in your ear
or you're driving they're coming out of
your speakers
wherever you are there's probably a ton
of information
around you like if you were to break it
into pixels it would be
a massive amount of data but because
you're a human in a body
you're able to prioritize what you think
is important at that moment and let
everything else
fade into the background which is called
the frame
so you can hear my voice and focus on
what i'm doing
while you're doing a very complex task
like
like driving and without putting
yourself in danger
um unless usually that activity doesn't
require
some kind of like logical deduction
right there's no representation
right there's no representation it's and
there's no logical deduction your
your body is attuned with its particular
sensitivities to the world based on its
body like it
to use merolopontine language the way
its body schema has been
configured as a consequence of its habit
and its life world
develops sensitivities to the world that
then enable it to operate
with these different kinds of like
prioritization of tasks that are
that that correspond to like
intentionality right like when you're
driving and listening to this
like your body is doing all this stuff
to attune itself
uh and be sensitive when it needs to be
sensitive to it without any logical it's
non-representational right no logical
deduction
one of the keys there is also that when
you are good at something you stop
thinking about it yeah exactly exactly
that's
the point like when you're driving along
you see you know you don't realize it
but you're like making all these little
micro muscular adjustments
on the steering wheel as you're driving
along because as we know no car will
ever go perfectly straight
on the road you can just take your hands
off the wheel and hit the pedal you
always are doing these little
tiny adjustments that's why if you are
drinking and driving or if you are
distracted while you're driving
there is a chance that you won't be
engaging in those sorts of
like unconscious movements that you do
you think it's really
you might make the mistake of thinking
that it's too easy and you
don't need to think about it but in in
in a dreyfus sense yeah you don't need
to think about it because
of what you were saying about becoming
attuned to being in the world
in that way yeah he has a beautiful
example that i really liked it was about
um
playing music uh in a village in spain
right where he says
if you think about somebody who's
playing guitar you know latin music
in spain they're probably not thinking
of the mind body problem right of the
fact that you know my hands have to
pluck these strings because my brain
tells me to uh they're probably not even
thinking of themselves as really
divorced or distinct from the instrument
right there's a kind of seamlessness
to their action uh you know where mind
body and instrument are one and that's
because they've done this for such a
long time
and that's not something you can get um
from just thinking about things
computationally you have to recognize
that there's an intention behind
playing this instrument and also a
memory of how this is done that's
carried on into the present in this
hadigarian sense
and that's projected into the future as
we try to play well
yeah skateboarding is also a great
example when you're learning to do that
it [ __ ]
sucks but once you get good at it it
becomes second nature
like imagine like if you've ever tried
to do a kickflip before you know
how many little tiny things you have to
coordinate perfectly
in order to get the board to flip over
and not shoot off to the side and
or not land on it funny and then sling
off and hit your head on the ground
like there is so much going on there and
as you become more skilled at some
activity
you think less about it and because it
you become almost
it becomes almost innate in a way but i
think like the phenomenological core
of this to get to the philosophy is kind
of
where where cyril put it like when when
you're a consciousness like
consciousness is always consciousness
of right it's not just in itself
conscious it's always conscious
of something in its environment so
intentionality
is maybe one way of talking about this
consciousness of
but i can hear i can hear the tech bros
already well i'll just i'll just program
my computer to have intentions what the
[ __ ] the problem
and you say well it's all these other
things too it's about
care it's about investedness all these
words we use to describe
our sort of our sort of uh what do you
say attachment
to the world our involvement in things
like those all have to do
yeah desiring wanting needing all these
things we use
to sort of orient ourselves and project
ourselves into the world like that's
fundamental to what
being conscious is so we're not talking
about
you know cyril will talk about mental
content
you know just simply like signs with
meanings attached to them
and they exist in your head and you
remember them and from a
phenomenological point of view that's
completely backwards you don't just have
meanings in your head you have meanings
because you're
in the world and you care about things
and you want to do things
and intentionality is maybe one
misleading sort of because
intentionality can
has some pitfalls talking about it in
just
simply goal-oriented activity for
instance
all computers have goal-oriented
activities
but i mean when you go out into the
world and you want to do something you
feel like you want something you might
not be so clear on what it is you want
what it is you desire and you might not
be also so clear on what it is exactly
that will fulfill
that want or desire you just kind of
have to get out there and try different
things on
and see what fits and and computers are
i mean when you talk about it that way
computers just seem like barely even on
the horizon
for those sorts of developments well
let's let's identify
here then quickly and make sure we
answer the objection fully
so if we have a one a one and a half
year old
we throw him on a mat and give him a
little obstacle course to walk around
he does it falls a few times what is the
difference between that one and a half
year old and the
the boston robotics thing whatever
that it's walking over stuff regaining
its balance
what's the difference there between the
intentional structure
i think there's a lot of different
things we can talk about some of which
eric mentioned right which is
uh you know the life world context in
which they exist and also the culture
that they're embedded in
one that i think isn't particularly
important that he points out is that
uh human beings tend to have it's hard
to put an ecstatic relationship to time
right where we draw on the reservoir of
our past experiences
our memories that inform whatever we're
doing in the present but also of course
uh what we're doing in the present is
informed equally as much by
how we're mobilizing our memories uh in
order to achieve something in the future
right does the one and a half year old
have that i think so yeah because again
they're drawing upon
their memory oh i fell down to try to
change their behavior right now
right but the reason why they're drawing
on their memory to change their behavior
right now isn't because they have
suffered a pain in the past just because
they're thinking
i don't want to fall down in the future
right like i did before
so there's this kind of unity to their
ecstatic experience of time
that's really difficult to emulate i
think in a computer program
there's this beautiful story by an
argentine author called uh
jose louise borge called funes uh the
memorials
forehead which is about a guy who
literally remembers everything
sorry yeah it's embarrassing
remembers absolutely everything in his
life every single detail
uh and the kind of point of the story is
this guy isn't super intelligent he
can't do anything right he just sits
there all day
regurgitating his memory of everything
that happened before because he can have
no intentionality
right he's not drawing upon some
specific event in his past
to mobilize him to do anything right now
right at the end of the story he says
my mind is just garbage you know it's
just a vast reservoir
of garbage well i think i think but i
think this is where i
sometimes find that cyril is a little
bit more decisive
because i think cyril can answer that
question about the boston dynamics robot
better
than dreyfus because ultimately
everything that the boston dynamics
robot is doing
is just following a syntactical
procedure yes it has algorithms right
people are like oh machine learning is
new but it's like no no
these are still symbol manipulations
it's rule following
it's adaptive rule following because
there's a rule for the program for when
it should adapt but that's still just a
more complicated mathematical
form of rule following but underlying
that is no
semantic content it's it's purely formal
procedure yeah that's sort of the tenor
i would take is that the robot's not
investing its environment with any kind
of meaning like my
my first thought is that when you put a
child down when like when you're even
doing these kinds of experiments you
need a carrot
right like usually you have the mother
sitting across the room or maybe some
doll or blanket that the child really
likes like you have to put something
there that the child
wants and then you put the obstacles
between it and it immediately has this
situation of well there's the thing i
want and these are the things that are
preventing me from getting it i have to
figure out how to get from here to there
and you kind of take advantage of this
intentional structure of consciousness
in order to perform the experiment
whereas with the robot
like you don't need to put its mother
there you don't need to put the person
who programmed it over there because all
robots want to just get back to the
programmer
it's you you just it's just yeah it's a
meaningless environment
rule-based it's going to be based not
much different from those sensors that
beep when you're about to back into
something with your car
except instead of the process being
automatic you have to hear the beep and
then
hit the brake or you're going to smash
the car behind you it's not really that
much different for one of those robots
this the whole thing is automated but
with a kid yeah it has that
again that intentional needful bodily
desiring structure
that we can manipulate in order to
extract
truths empirical data out of the
out of the experiment whereas with a
robot we're not trying to figure out
what is the nature of a robot
that it would be able to navigate these
obstacles we're
probably doing some kind of experiment
on the our programmings
you know the quality of the code we've
written for this specific program
i mean the like every aspect of it is
different when you get into the weeds of
it
but i think i think ponce i think yeah i
don't know it's weird that
your victor's explanation of how cyril
would talk about it
is very good but then there's also room
for
for sort of dreyfus's phenomenological
approach to like what the kid would be
sort of well what's funny about what
well i think what's interesting about
this is like i do
think that like ultimately like mira
laponte
in phenomenology is similarly decisive
in its objection to kind of like strong
ai views but the problem is
i think that to really understand why
you have to really do the work to go and
spend a lot of time like it would be
hard for us to explain all the
implications of mira laponte and
phenomenology in a podcast format
like we could give a little taste of it
and i think we have in the past
but to really see why it's decisive it's
it would take i think
a fairly long time whereas i think
searle's arguments are like
very clean cut and kind of stand and
fall on a very neat distinction
you can explain clearly and for that
reason i find it has more utility
against the techno bros
than mariluponte does because it's like
a quick thing and i would say i think
that actually these two authors are
complementary
in many different ways i think that
you're absolutely right victor that in
order to explain why they're
complimentary we need like a million
more shows
you know and i also think that cyril's
arguments are cleaner you know it's easy
to explain
it's straight to the point whereas
buying into everything dreyfus says
is a little bit more complicated but i
think that you know again you see
in both of them a kind of echo of the
early 20th century turn away from
materialist interpretations of cartesian
rationalism to
use a jargon-filled phrase right
basically this idea that all the mind is
is a logical machine
that represents the world to itself and
this can be understood best in terms of
following rules uh about how best to
interpret quantitative data
right they're both criticizing that from
different angles and i think heidegger
who's the major influence on dreyfus and
wittenstein who's a major influence on
searle a lot of complementary critiques
uh of these kinds of flavors of
materials cartesianism there's one place
i think we could go
with our with our one and a half year
old still that i i think might
differentiate the two and that's that
well eric got us
ninety percent of the way there by
saying we need its mother or a toy
in the room and that will get it to to
draw it to a source of meaning but even
if it had nothing
if it was just in a room with an
obstacle course that kid's still gonna
go get bored go start looking around for
stuff
go put its mouth on stuff feel stuff
maybe try to walk
it'll create because it already has that
openness
the meaning structure i think we get on
an ontake openness
to get to get really jargony but it's
going to create
meaning even in an empty room whereas
no matter how many thousands of years
that robot sits there for
it's never once gonna try to do that and
even i don't think that cyril's
biological um
survival i mean it'll get hungry but
let's just say it's not hungry
even if you take out that biological
aspect to it
for whatever reason that one-year-old is
going to start doing stuff
with stuff for almost no reason
yeah tool use is one of the most like i
think dreyfus makes a really
convincing argument about the use of
tools
and the sorts of activities that we
sink into when we're doing something
that we're familiar with like
you know carpentry fixing a car or
children at play right like they're not
picking up their toys and
and trying to discover what they are
they just sort of engage in play and
their
their consciousness or whatever you want
to call it is immersed in the activity
whereas with a machine it can only ever
be a sort of objective observer of these
things it can never
give itself over and that's why i wanted
to mention that
you know i think as much as we think
yeah there's complementary aspects of
cyril
and and and dreif is here but i think i
think that
dreyfus's argument would go for weak ai
too
because he those two assumptions that he
says that ais
make that they never tend to criticize
because they're
just too optimistic about any little
success they have
never mind the grand failures is the
epistemological assumption
he says that all intelligent behavior
can be simulated
and the mode of information is just
detached disembodied
objective observer you know you're
outside and
the other one's the ontological
assumption that
you know everything incen everything
that's essential
to intelligent behavior are just little
determinate
sets of independent elements called
logical atomism
like dividing the universe into discrete
particles or packets and then trying to
give those things meaning one by one
which is what if you were to think of
everything as a programmer
and program all of that into your little
device
and make it do exactly what the child
does
like you're still not simulating a
child's behavior
you're you're simulating a program's
ability to mimic the
behavior of the child but there's no
mind there
and there's no simulation of a mind
they're just two different things
because one of them's working with those
assumptions and the other one
is not when we're observing the child
we're not making those assumptions
one place where i think that that there
is a compatibility
is i think that you know they're in very
different senses but i think
clearly dreyfus is is in his emphasis on
embodied engagement with the world
there's a way in which he's calling
attention to the fact that human beings
are a kind of
you know for lack of a better word
animal with sensitivities to the world
there's there's
it's like it's it's analog as opposed to
digital it's like one
kind of analogy that i that i had in my
head that maybe i'm not gonna be able to
explain very well but i think
what cyril is doing like i think
sometimes it sounds like sterling is
being a biological
reductionist because he talks about the
brain as being essentially a biological
process which is why
it couldn't ever be reproduced by purely
syntactical rule following
but i think like the reason that there's
a compatibility is because ultimately
um when you're when you're like you're
calling attention to the fact that
there's
more than just i guess being able to
reduce things down to kind of atomistic
rule following and i guess like what
what an animal or a being in the world
is doing is not
um reducible to simples logical simples
you know i [ __ ] i feel like i lost my
train of thought here guys why don't you
go to the distinction between
passive and active because one thing
dreyfus always emphasizes
is that perception even doing nothing
is still an active process whereas
within that biological framework
you don't need that to be world creation
you don't need activity
on behalf of the perceiver for that to
work right and actually
and actually that was kind of like the
point that i was bringing up way earlier
in this discussion we were talking about
terminator 2 and i said something like
okay
if a computer became self-aware why
would it care about anything
like like if you could if somehow a
computer could be aware
that it is a computer there's like no
additional material in it
for it to continue like world creating
because it's just like okay
so what like why would i care about
anything like like because
there's many more like conditions of
possibility that are necessary for
something to be a world-creating
existential being with with what we
identify as consciousness
and the survival instincts by the if
that is an instinct if it's real
if there's a biological cause for us
needing to survive or wanting to survive
that still doesn't explain fully
what it's evolved into in human beings
at least because it doesn't seem
like we're that interested in base
survival
almost ever and that's the thing that
you can even see in
the one and a half year old he's gonna
go make a world out of an empty room
even though he even before linguistic
acquisition
before any of the complex social
cultural interactions that we talk about
adults having
that kid still does that yeah i think
this is one of the
ways that i'd push back on something
eric said even though this wasn't
intentional when he said you know
computers
we were talking about objectivity
because i think graphics would actually
take the stronger
line that it's impossible to be
objective in the sense of seeing
objects uh if you just take the
materials reductionist perspective
because
to abstract away from the infinite
amount of data into the world
something that you call an object that
has significance to
you there has to be something like an
intentionalist quality behind that
like when i look at the world and i say
house right
i'm abstracting a certain piece of the
world
away from the internet connection a
collection of data out there to say that
this is this specific object and it has
the meaning house to me
because i know what that word means in
my life world
right i mean it'd be very difficult for
a computer if you brought it into the
city
uh to look around and say oh house right
i'm gonna break down all the
quantitative data
that's available to me and single this
out as particularly important
because it just doesn't perceive the
world that way it doesn't even perceive
the kind of objects that we perceive
yeah
that's why we have those uh captcha
tests
yeah i mean that's i was using the term
objective kind of i know in the shooting
like disinterested kind of sense like
almost almost like the kantian sense of
of you know standing back and evaluating
something like
like someone might think like of a of an
analogy
which is a bad one that like when an
artist has an idea the idea is like the
program
and then the artist just simply carries
out the program you know you step back
and you think about something
and then you just sort of mechanically
carry out the process
which is not the case with humans
because humans
have conscious control and thought and
that's really kind of what separates us
from
a pure survival instinct because in that
case we can make mistakes computers do
not make mistakes
this is a strange maybe thing to say but
that's the truth computers do not
make mistakes there is no such thing as
a computer making a mistake
it doesn't make sense to even use that
unless there's a unless there's a bit
flip
if you've heard of that where like a
piece of radiation can make a bit in the
program flip
but that's not the company maybe but
that's an external thing that's an
external is a meteorite hitting the
earth humans making a mistake no exactly
no
that's exogenous it's not endogenous to
the system you're right yeah computers
we should have seen it yeah but
computers don't make mistakes the
programmers make mistakes there's some
kind of circumstance that throws it off
its program you know you can picture the
robot falling over for some reason and
then its legs are still carrying out the
program it's just not going anywhere
it doesn't make mistakes it sounds it's
a weird thing because we think about
computers making mistakes
all the time the system had an error you
know this the
that's the favorite uh excuse of our of
our university administrations oh sorry
computer error you'll have to
come back later you know it's it's
interesting because you're making you're
reminding me of
like i think there's a podcast i
listened to that talked about when
computer simulations started taking over
a lot of
uh uh roles for certain kinds of civil
engineers so there's one
that there is like this giant uh
topographically accurate map
of the united states coastlines that
were used to be used
to simulate flooding and like what would
happen when certain flooding would occur
and they stopped using it in favor of
computer models but what they found was
that the computer models
didn't end up being as predictive as the
physical model where you have real water
on like a semi on like
a model of the coastline and part of the
reason is because fluid dynamics
it's almost like the resolution is too
fine grain for a computer to reduce
the the fluid the fluid dynamics down to
an accurate enough
place i mean it's close the the
predictions are close
but it's not quite enough it doesn't
quite have a high enough resolution
because ultimately
a computer still has to reduce down
these like material forces into
um syntactical like you know it has to
like reduce things down to digital
models which is not analog right so
there's gonna be
some resolution loss in the accuracy
of that this is what dreyfus calls the
frame problem
is that conscious lookers
us we know what we're looking for
before we have all the data almost we
anticipate the data whereas the computer
has to gather all the data
and then make decisions from that and
barring some cases like
i don't know unsupervised machine
learning which probably none of us know
enough to talk about
which might be something different than
that but
the resolution problem is one that is
very easy for
humans to deal with and very difficult
for
computers to deal with just like
self-driving cars we know
what kind of things it's okay to run
over if it runs into the street
like uh a dog versus a person
children all right a child um
so we know we can make those decisions
immediately whereas a computer has to be
told within certain parameters exactly
what it's supposed to do in each of
those situations
and they're i guess still trying to iron
out the
the bugs in that yeah yeah
you know the irobot thing where the the
child's dying and he's like save the
child
it goes oh yeah that's a terrible movie
interesting that that book was written
by isa isaac asimov in 1950
about 17 years before dreyfuss wrote
this article we've been reading
and if you remember like ggek's parable
of the map
this reminded me a bit of what pills was
talking about actually kind of is this
the borgies
parable of the map uh the borge
okay yes i think uh he might have drawn
from barbados that comes back in the
same episode
uh the idea is like he says you know
think about a map it's one of those
extreme examples what would be the best
kind of map and he says
uh you know there's this kingdom they
try to come up with one that's
completely accurate and then they
realize that they just
have to create a giant piece of paper
that includes everything
in the kingdom and then they lay the
piece of paper over the kingdom and the
kingdom disappears because it's now
as big as the literal mass they're
trying to create
and the point of the story is look like
you can't just sit there
and get anything useful from trying to
give every bit of information possible
uh
you need to kind of abstract away from
the infinite complexity of the world to
provide create a map that's useful for
people who want to actually achieve
something you know go from one city to
another
beaudry odd baby i don't know if g-check
uses that too
it's definitely bode your yard so you
know this idea that we can see if we
simulate every neuron of a brain in a
computer then like that that computer
will somehow become
start creating conscious states and i
think um cyril has
like i think a very like good uh
reaction to that right where he says um
you know one can imagine a computer
simulation of an of the action of
peptides in the in the hypothalamus that
is accurate down to the last synapse
but equally one can imagine a computer
simulation of the oxidation of the
hydrocarbons in a car engine or the
action of
digestive processes in a stomach when it
is digesting
uh pizza and the simulation is no more
real a real thing than in the case of
the brain
than it is in the case of the car or the
stomach barring miracles you could not
run your car by doing a computer
simulation of the oxidation of gasoline
and you could not digest pizza by
running the program that simulates the
stomach
uh it seems obvious that a simulation of
cognition will similarly not produce the
effects
of the neurobio biology of cognition
yeah that's a fun it's a fun
responsibility yeah
i mean i don't know i don't know how i
like his his idea of like
rescuing the mind by appealing to
semantics saying
but none of it would have any meaning i
don't i don't know if that even fits
into those like uh
what you can't simulate those processes
because they're physical processes
happening somewhere else and then your
simulation
or your model of those processes would
not be the thing itself
i mean that's that point is well taken
it is but it's
but it's not oh yeah that part's well
sorry it can finish i mean
no that's as far as i was going to get i
mean the simulation is not the thing
itself it doesn't duplicate the process
it just simulates it which can be useful
for other purposes like if you're a
gastronomy a student and you want to
study how the digestion system works
right yeah look at that model that would
be great like because you can't watch
yourself digesting something so go for
it
but i think it's it's it's it's
important and it's related to the syntax
versus
semantics because i think his point is
like this simulations are just
syntactical processes but i think a lot
of a lot of techno bros make this
mistake where they think oh like
because there's a there's a kind of bias
towards thinking that
consciousness is something immaterial it
feels intuitive that oh if i could just
simulate it then it's going to create
this similar experience of something
that doesn't have
a substance and he's just like no no
like it has a substance the brain is
this has like a bio physical substance
just like
other biological processes have a
a kind of substance right and he says
that it would be ridiculous to think
that you could
run a computer program that is again
just a procedure
rule following um and i and i like i
find it amusing he says sort of like
the strong thesis of ai is that any
system whatsoever whether whether it is
made of beer cans silicon chips or
toilet paper
not only might have thoughts and
feelings but must have thoughts and
feelings provided only
that it implements the right program
right with the impetus with the right
inputs and outputs
um i think that's that's a profoundly
anti-biological view is kind of his
point right a lot of these people it's
like saying the
the simulation of digestion a perfect
simulation of the digestive system is no
more
digestion than a perfect simulation of a
brain
would be consciousness exactly exactly
you know that elon musk said it's very
unlikely
that we don't live in a simulation in
like uh
in a higher the universe is a simulation
in a higher advanced species computer
because it's almost impossible that they
wouldn't have done that already
that sounds like another episode we
don't know nothing about computers
really how they work or brains for that
matter
but next week stay tuned because we will
have a
neuro scientist on here no
cognitive science of sciences different
different different but i'm sure she
she knows more about brains than we do
softer science
there were some things that we didn't
get a chance to get to like there's like
some good objections that
that cyril addresses like to the chinese
room which i guess we won't talk about
but
i find them funny right a lot of people
said that it's not the person
that's conscious it's the whole room
that's conscious
the room is the system's response the
system's response it's conscious even
though
the the program itself isn't conscious
but the whole room becomes
conscious because of a consequence of
its of its
following the program yeah that's not
too far from like an extended mind
kind of perspective that that certainly
is going to say i don't mind that too
i think no i mean i mean that's where a
lot of these extended mind theses that
like the
you know when the when the uh when the
person who's blind is using the walking
stick
they're they're not so much like
grabbing a tool
consciously and then like examining the
responses that just no their
consciousness is just sort of extended
through the stick and it's how they
get through the world they're skilled
with it so they don't think about it so
it becomes almost
part of them and cyril would probably
hate that
but you know ponte is a huge influence
behind that way of thinking
and he uses the blind man and the kane
example all the time but
but that's but i think that's different
than uh than like you know some
like emergent property from from
following a syntactical procedure
right like i mean i think his other
thought experiment to respond to that
concern is like
you know imagine you had like a million
like chinese people like organized in a
way that they're following a computer
process that simulates
the brain then would would all of the
sudden those million chinese people
become a conscious brain
following that computer procedure uh
like yeah
why do they have to be chinese just
because the room's chinese yeah
i think he just wanted continuity
between chinese i had a question about
chinese do
do like all the chinese languages like
mandarin and
cantonese do that was the same script
because why does he even say
if i see chinese letters it's a good
question i think the thing that might
have
said no i think it was also probably
just a 1980s thing
yeah you probably didn't need to be as
woke about that then as you do now
i often feel like when you go order at a
chinese restaurant and there's no
english translation on the menu you are
in a chinese room experiment
well thank god they usually have the
numbers yeah and then you don't know
what you're gonna get but they think you
do
so they're like yeah a human is
definitely ordering this food and then
they bring it to you
and you're like oh [ __ ] i ordered pork
all right so we i mean i think this is
invariably just a very difficult thing
to
hash out right there's a reason why
philosophy of mind is all over the place
you know there's people like david
chalmers that say consciousness is
a separate like real thing uh that can't
be captured by materials reductionism
then you have people like daniel dennett
who say that's completely out there we
can't have it
so there's no consensus on this right
that's
i not an intractable problem but i think
as close to an intractable problem well
it is but but i do find uh like i think
that
i'm very convinced by both cyril and
dreyfuss that like uh that that digital
computers cannot cause consciousness and
i personally i mean maybe this the our
listeners
some of them will disagree and they
won't because we didn't maybe
uh do enough to make it clear for them
but to me like the arguments are so
decisive that it's like embarrassing
that people still believe
uh that we can create consciousness from
digital computers because
once i feel like you have that insight
it just becomes so obvious to me i don't
know
if other people feel the same but i
think that there's a long history of
that in
european thought right i mean what
they're attacking with
strong ai theses is again not really all
that different from what you saw
various forms of materials cartesianism
wanting to achieve in the early 20th
century
uh which was to reduce the world down to
a set of quantitative facts
that could be represented to the mind
right it's this very convincing picture
that people who think of themselves as
scientifically minded like
and i think what they're both just doing
from different angles is saying again
it's not going to happen because the
mind is more complex
than just that it's not that we don't
represent quantitative data to us in a
certain way
in fact we probably wouldn't get very
far as a species if we weren't capable
of doing that
but the mind at least as far as we know
does a lot more
and there are good reasons uh to accept
that kind of argument because i agree
with victor i don't know why
it is that so many people struggle with
this uh beyond
the cultural appeal of this image of a
completely rational mind
that only sees things the way it is the
way it is
uh and doesn't make any non impartial
judgment one of the reasons for it is
that it just
feels phenomenologically you could say
it just feels like
your mind is pretty independent of the
world like the world's out there
it's doing stuff it's not telling me
what to do
so that thus consciousness must be
something
disembodied or floating or soul-like or
something like that
but what merlou ponti would say i mean
dreyfus with merlot ponte
would say is that the only reason that
you have that feeling
is because since you are a one and a
half year old bumping into things
you've become so familiar with
everything that it feels like you are
over here
and everything else is over there but
you don't need to have a separate order
of representation
to explain your feeling of consciousness
all you need is a lot of experience
which all of the adults at oxford and
mit at berkeley
all of us have this amount of experience
that we can talk about it as something
distinct
but the fact is that it's this very slow
building process that
takes years and years to acquire uh
you know coherency such a good point i
think like
that that there's a kind of bias built
into just the way we experience the
world phenomenologically that makes it
seem
that way and you know i think it is
worth the re-emphasizing like to the to
the techno
if there are any you know like really
techno optimists who who like this idea
that we can create consciousness that
you know they think they're being really
materialist in
in thinking that a computer can can
create consciousness
but it's like you know worth emphasizing
the implication of
of cyril's argument in particular that
really by believing that you are
actually
committing the same flaw that people who
believe in an immaterial soul are
committing which is that
consciousness all the way back yeah that
you're you're actually you're actually
accepting the same assumption as if
there's a there's an immortal soul
because for you
uh a computer program which has no
material
biological like um rootedness
you separate the two you're actually
committing a kind of dualism um
so i think like you know really that
it's it's not the materialist
position to actually take this this
techno-utopianist view that we can
create consciousness through
uh like but through kind of um
syntactical formal uh rule following
i'm also going to venture a thesis by
saying that i think
part of the reason why people are
attracted to this view is precisely that
it has deep roots in european thought
of the sorts that we've discussed before
i also think it's just because a lot of
people who put forward these kind of
arguments and i'll use merlot ponte's
terms
uh are intellectuals intellectual lists
things like
intellectual well no i know that's just
term intellectual list but i'm actually
meaning it as more colloquial term
because it's very easy if you are an
intellectual to assume that
what exists are ideas you know symbol
manipulation of a certain sword right
and to give into that conceit it's not
something that you would see
somebody like the people dreyfus talking
about uh like a musician
right or what heidegger's talking about
a barrel maker fall into
because they're very aware of the fact
that they're embedded in this world of
meanings
and that their body plays a role in
structuring
their interpretation of the world in a
way that i think a lot of intellectuals
aren't
since frankly we get a lot of our inputs
about the world from books
symbols right yeah i mean i think that's
just a
i don't want to go too far with that
because i think it's just a kind of
crude anthropology on my apartment
if you're not an intellectual uh you
know getting where's my coffee you know
what i mean
well it's also it's i think also it's
just like the classic
maybe motivation that people ascribe to
religious people who believe in the
immaterial soul which is this fear of
dying right so like
if our consciousness really is just a
computer program
a syntactical program then we could
download our consciousness into a
computer and live forever as many of the
techno utopianists believe
but if in fact it's actually the case
that uh our consciousness is
uh irreparably rooted in our bodies and
in the flesh
of our of of our biological substance
then there's no getting around that
and uh and you're just and there's no
possibility that you're going to be able
to live forever
control the old the old thesis of
control
i i think when you get out of the weeds
of this stuff and you look back on it i
mean this is my takeaway is that neither
of them say
it's sort of not gonna happen i guess
you could say
that ai will develop so far that
something like consciousness
will be able to be made by a human being
i don't think anyone
or any of these guys are going to make
predictions because that's stupid
making predictions about technology is
just opening up
yourself to all kinds of grief and
nobody's predicting that nobody makes
predictions about technology but i can
bring you to grief
i think the the main difference between
these guys when you get out of the weeds
strafes and searle and you look back
and say okay dreyfus says maybe it's
possible but i don't think so
i think it's in principle impossible
that machines will ever be conscious
and searle says i think it's in
principle
i think it's possible and i'm i'm not
going to say whether or not it will
happen
but it could happen but not that's the
sort of you can't like that's a hair you
just can't split between the two of them
like yeah that's cyril
thinks it's in principle but not he has
his examples and his syntactics and
semantics and
and then and then dreyfus has his
different perspective of you know you
need a body and phenomenology and
you have to be invested in the world and
and you know and i love his examples of
when these processes break down
is when you really see them you know you
have intentions you don't even realize
i have all these cups sitting on my desk
i reached out
and grabbed one and took a drink out of
it got oh god that's not what i thought
was in there and you see the
the sort of intentional process break
down whereas that would
never happen to a computer because as i
said they do not make mistakes
and making mistakes is how living things
learn and the more mistakes we make the
more we learn
right and computers don't make mistakes
so they don't
learn in the sense that i'm using the
word
they learn maybe but again i don't know
enough about deep learning algorithms to
pronounce on that to be fair to be fair
to searle though like he would say that
in principle
uh a digital computer in principle could
never be conscious
well i think so like so like for based
on our boolean logic or
the way that code's written now i i
think there could be a possibility i
don't i don't think that he thinks in i
think he thinks in principle any any
sort of
uh system that's based on syntactical
symbol manipulation could never create
consciousness
so he just says maybe we'll be able to
make a physical machine
based on some other physical material
that can create
consciousness maybe but he has no idea
what that would be he's like anything
that's based on syntax impossible
like i think in the beginning he really
lays it out and says you know can a
machine
think and he says maybe it'll maybe
it'll turn out to be impossible but
there's nothing in principle
stopping this from happening but maybe
it will be impossible but we do not know
yet
and i think yeah dreyfus says we do not
know yet but i think
in principle that it is impossible
that's what i'm saying
i think is the main difference there the
upshot
and then everything else is getting into
the weeds beyond that once you come out
and take
step back and take a look i think their
different methods bring them to that
sort of
last conclusion on whether it's possible
or not
well i think i think i think cyril bases
that just on the fact that human beings
are biological
machines that exist in the world so
therefore in principle there must be
some method
maybe to make something but it just
wouldn't be based on anything that we
would know
yeah i think that that's a a very sound
position to take right i mean
we do not have nearly enough information
about the nature of the brain
uh to talk about how to use this
terminology produces the mind
right that he says you know the mind is
what the brain does so
the brain is ultimately just a
collection of physical materials
and it can produce a mind obviously it's
possible in principle for physical
materials to produce a mind
but that's not what digital hardware
does right yeah that's not even
and he's kind of tries to set that
question aside to just be like well
that's not really what we're talking
about and he's just saying that to be
like i'm not trying to make room for a
soul here i'm just telling you that like
uh like like digital computers is not
sufficient in principle for anything
that's conscious
and i think pills i think was pills who
said that put it really well he's kind
of like look
since we do know that in principle it's
possible for physical material to
produce a mind
maybe we could build an actual mind at
some point
but that would mean fundamentally
changing the background assumptions that
we have about what it is that the mind
does
i'll just side with spinoza that the
mind is the image of the body but
we've been going for a while and i think
some of it's friday
not for us it's friday for them so maybe
they want to go get unconscious
while they still have the chance i i did
just want to i did
i did just want to like say quickly like
what we read in case the listeners want
to
go and find it we read from scientific
america
john searles is the brain's mind a
computer program
and then we read the 1967 piece from
herbert dreyfus in review of metaphysics
why computers must have bodies in order
to be intelligent which he rewrote as
what computers can't do i think three
five years later
a few years later yeah i think so anyway
something like that
anyway guys uh good thanks
maybe we all live in a simulation techno
uh optimus get at me on twitter i'll
fight you
yeah go fight victor i don't want to
argue with you so
all right peace peace
[Music]
bye